The answer to that is we can find a group of four genes that are connected to each other
by selecting this one here, this one here, this one here, and this one here
and as you will see, this gene here is connected to those three.
This gene here is connected to that one, that one, and that one.
This one up here is also connected to this one, this one, and this one
and similarly here the fourth one is also connected to the other three.
That is actually the largest possible group of genes that you can find
that are all connected to each other in this network.
Now it should be noted that this problem is a bit of a simplification of what you might
encounter in a real biotechnology setting.
For example, normally in biotechnology you would be happy if you found a group of genes where
most are connected to most others but here we'll be looking
only for groups that are fully connected to each other so like this one here.
The reason why we're doing that is that from an algorithmic perceptive,
it doesn't really make much difference and it's just simply to work with the problem
where we know we have to find groups of genes that are fully connected to each other
rather than if we allow certain connections to be missing.